مشاهدينا من مستشفى الملك عبد الله
التخصصي الاطفال بوزاره الحرس الوطني
بالرياض ينضم الينا مراسله العربيه هاني
الصفيان اهلا بك يا هاني لتحدث هاني عن
العمليه الرابعه والخمسين في سلسله عمليات
فصل التوائم الجاريه في السعوديه كيف تسير
المرحله الثانيه من هذه العمليه
نعم اهلا بكم مره ثانيه قناه العربيه طبعا
نعم هي حاله الفصل الاول اجراء العمليات
هي رقم 54 وايضا هي الخامسه بالنسبه لتوام
سيامي همم قدموا من العراق طبعا الان في
المراحل او المرحله الثالثه في عمليه
الفصل بعد انتهاء من مرحله التخدير وكذلك
مرحله التطهير ولاعلنا نشاهد الان الطاقه
الطبيه السعودي الذي يقوم بعمليه الفصل
واجراء عمليه الفاصل وكذلك التجهيزات
والاستعدادات همم فصل التوام السيامي عمر
وعلي ايضا سوف يكون معي بشكل سريع الدكتور
او البروفيسور اسامه المشهداني الذي قدم
يوم امس من بغداد والذي ايضا همم انضم الى
الفريق الطبي السعودي لمتابعه ايضا عمليه
فصل التوائم السيامي عمر وعلي مرحبا بك
بروفيسور ولكن دائما نتحدث اليوم
انك قدمت همم احد همم الاطباء من العراق
كيف تشاهد التجهيزات والاستعدادات الطبيه
للتوام السيامي عمر وعلي شكرا هاني وتحيه
لك ولي مشاهدينا العربيه احيقه انا وصلت
البارحه من بغداد الى همم السعوديه الى
الرياض حي قد نزلت المستشفى امبارح واليوم
في المستشفى من الصباح وهو سوف اشارك في
العمليه في المرحله الرابعه والخامسه على
الاغلبيه ان شاء الله الان احنا في
المرحله الثالثه
اطمن مشاهدي السعوديه العربيه انه الامور
تمام لحد الان وتبشروا بخير المرحله
الاولى تمت هي مرحله التحذير وهي من مرحله
الصعبه والمعقده اثارت اكثر من ساعه مجرد
بشكل سهل جدا لمرحله ثانيه ايضا الام
مرحله الثالثه
والرابعه الثالثه والرايه من اهم المراحل
يعني عمليه فصل الكبد والقناه الصفراويه
ولا مع كذلك حقيقه التجهيزات الموجوده
تجهيزات على مستوى عالي جدا قد تكون هي
الافضل على مستوى العالم في موضوع التخدير
في موضوع الاجهزه المستعمله في في عمليه
الفصل
والاهم من ذلك هو التحضير العمليه
للاسترخصت ثلاث ثلاث الى اربعه اشهر
استقبلوا اطفال في مستشفى الملك عبد الله
في العنايه المركزه ووضعه وممدات للجلد في
سبيل يتوسع على الجلد يقرر تغطيه مكان ال-
ال- الفراغ اللي راح تصير بالعمليه
سؤال الثاني
ايضا عمليه اجراء العمليه طبعا هذا الباب
هو يتم التحكم به من الخارج بعد عدم اللمس
وذلك حفاظا ايضا على سلامه الطبيه لعدم
الدخول اي من الجراثيم الى داخل غرفه
عمليتها هذه تعتبر هذه من غرفه العمليات
المخصصه لفصل التوام السيامي وهي معقمه
بالكامل والان تتم عمليات اجراءات العمليه
الفصل كما تحدث الدكتور اسامه نعود مره
اخرى دكتور اسامه اليك الان تحدثت انك سوف
تشارك في ال- ال- المرحله الرابعه
والخامسه ما هي هذه المرحله كيف نتحدث
عنها العمليه يعني
ست مراحل
11 ساعه ان شاء الله المرحله الثالثه
مرحله فتح ال- ال- الجلد وفصل الجلد من
همم
من الصدر من البطن المرحله الثاني الثالثه
والرابعه راح تتضمن هي مرحله فصل الكبد
وهي اهم مرحله لانه نعتقد ان الاطفال يعني
مشتركين في غشاء القلب وفي الكبد فصل
الكبد والقناه الصفراويه هي اهم مرحله
لنبيها نسبه همم نزف الاسامحها الله
الفريق الطبي السعودي قد هو يعني متمررس
المملكه العربيه السعوديه الفريق متخصص
والهو خبره كبيره جدا باضافه الاجهزه
الموجوده اللي هي ارجون ليزر الكوزه معي
في حياته اجزاء
الامواج فوق الصوتيه كل الاجهزه حديثه في
مصر كبد بدون ما اسعد عندنا نزف شكرا
اذا كان هذا هو حديث همم المهندس همم عفوا
البروفيسور اسامه المشهداني الذي سوف
يشارك مع الفريق الطبي السعودي في عمليه
همم الفصل وكذلك تحديدا في المرحله
الخامسه كما تحدثت ايضا نشاهد الدكتور عبد
الله الربيع الان يقوم بعمليه اجراء الفصل
الطبي من حوله وكذلك دكتور رئيس
مستشفى الملك عبدالله التخصص للاطفال
همم
الوقت تحياتي لك وانت معنا في مستشفى
الملك عبد الله التخصصي الاطفال بوزاره
الحرس الوطني بالرياض العربيه يعني